welcome everyone to another tutorial on
selenium webdriver
in which we are going to talk about what
exactly is in selenium
and why exactly we are going to use this
selenium webdriver here
now uh in this one there are different
topics which we are going to talk about
let's go through that one
first we are going to talk about what
exactly is selenium all about because
that's a basic topic which we need to
cover
then uh we will be talking about what is
the purpose of
uh using selenium webdriver in which
which situations we can actually use the
selenium whip driver here and then we
are going to talk about the selenium
webdriver framework
the framework which is specifically
designed for the selenium web driver
the various drawbacks of the selenium
drip driver and ultimately at the last
we will be talking about a demonstration
over here
which is all about the selenium web
driver like how exactly
uh we can make use of a web driver as a
linear web driver in
action which can help us to go for some
uh
real time executions of some test
scenarios
uh opening up some website or doing some
execution so all that stuff is what we
are going to talk about
in this whole tutorial over here now
coming back to the main topic so let's
start with the what exactly is a
selenium here
now software automation uh is something
which is
a kind of uh minimum requirement
every organization is having nowadays
because
they were doing a lot of stuff manually
in the previous situations and it was
consuming a lot of time
but until then we were not having the
frameworks like selenium which was
giving the
users or the the automation engineers a
whole total a different exposure there
now testing is always an important part
of a software development here it's it's
something which
uh gives a very a high level of
value add-ons to overall exposure or the
overall
sdlc cycle here without the software
testing
it's not possible for an organization to
release its source code till production
environment
and it makes sense also because the
testing is
very important even nowadays if we have
to procure a new car
or a vehicle we basically go for a test
drive now
this is something which we are using
because of the fact that
we want to experience the exposure there
like how
in real time we can see uh the vehicle
in
action whether all my requirements is
getting fulfilled or not
so you have your own parameters everyone
have its own parameters
so you just want to address those
parameters and want to see that if
this product is something which can take
care of all your requirements or not
so that's something keeping in mind
software testing is very important
and whether it's a manual whether it's
an automated testing in both the cases
it's very important for the software
yes over the period of time the
organization felt that manual testing is
actually
uh is not efficient as compared to the
automation testing secondly it takes a
lot of time of the end users to do that
uh
different processing and you know any
kind of uh
you know test scenarios if he wants to
execute he wants to go ahead with that
so that's something which takes a lot of
time but in case of
the automation test cases we have lot of
frameworks
which can help us to drive like how the
implementation should be done
so keeping in mind selenium is one of
the tool which is available there
and the whole focus of selenium is to
provide a framework of
provide an automation which can generate
a
quite efficient uh results for you and
results
these results which we are talking about
these results are something which we are
talking about like how
exactly we are getting the high level of
efficiency
so when we are talking about selenium so
it gives us a lot of
benefits and a lot of exposure so um
you talking about the websites when we
talk about websites we deal like okay
um you know if i have to validate my
website i have to do the login i have to
access the application
so that's how i will be doing the
verification but
with the help of selenium kind of
frameworks we don't have to do these
things
manually anymore we have this automation
tool which can help us to drive the
things
it will automatically open the browser
go to the specific website
put some inputs clicking on some buttons
generating the responses
and taking up the actions so ultimately
it will help you to drive each and
everything from the beginning to the end
most of the organizations after the
deployment actually have written the
test cases like the sanity testing and
the smoke testing
in case of the selenium like a
particular selenium test cases will be
executing
it will try to validate it if the
application is working fine as expected
or not
just try to you know have a kind of a
brief uh
overview or you can say like
introduction here like
this so and so steps you have to execute
this one so uh procedure you have to
execute
to follow a complete procedure or
complete automation here
so keeping in mind selenium is one of
the open source tool which is available
there for this purpose of writing the
test cases test
automation there any kind of web portal
can be easily verified and tested along
with the help of selenium
it's something which can be created like
the test scripts can be easily created
across
different programming languages it's not
like since
selenium is written in the java
programming language so you can only
use this one for the java programming
language it's not like that
it's pretty generic which means like any
programming languages
if you feel you want to use you can use
selenium for that so it's having the
compatibility
with the java c shaft python a variety
of
applications uh programming languages
can be used with the help of selenium so
it doesn't mean like
you are only stuck with one language so
uh it helps you to gain the benefits
also because
once you are comfortable selenium then
pretty much any programming languages
you can automate
and if you see like most of the
automation engineers are actually having
the understanding of selenium only
because this gives them the comfort that
with this one single programming
language
they will be able to handle like all the
different programming languages
uh related work whether it's a c sha
whether it's a dot net it's a java
a node.js or any kind of programming
languages there so selenium is having
the comfort
or is having the compatibility with that
also uh in case of selenium it's not
only about one test cases
we can pretty much create test suits
like heavy test suits
uh you can create the regulation test
suits you can create the uat test source
you can create the sanity testing or the
smoke testing kind of test source
so there are different kind of test
suits which you can create here
now these test suits actually have a
bunch of test cases
integrated like it's not only about one
test case
or it's not only about two test cases
it's kind of a bunch of test cases which
we are trying to create with the help of
selenium
so selenium is something in which we
basically create a multiple
uh test cases it's a combination of
multiple test cases all together into a
single one so that's
what we call it as a kind of selenium
test suit here
right now the selenium test suit is
comprising of
four different tools here the very first
one is the selenium remote control
second one is the selenium grid then we
got selenium ide
and ultimately last we have the selenium
whip driver so these are the four
different tools which we got over here
with the moment we talk about this
selenium suit here
now let's talk about this selenium web
driver because that's the whole focus of
this
uh content over here to see like what
exactly is
the selenium web driver and how we can
go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium web
driver so here a
selenium web driver is one of the most
important component of the saline
test suit when we talk about the
selenium
uh tools suit over here like uh we talk
about okay i want to create a whole
together regression test suit so
selenium webdriver is very important
component for that
and when we talk about uh the selenium
webdriver it allows the cross
browser compatibility which means like
you want to test your applications you
can have a test suit there one for the
chrome browser one for the firefox
one for the internet explorer you can
then say like okay i want to test and
validate my application
across all these three browsers and in
future if safari browser comes in
all you have to do is like you have to
just run the same script
with the web driver of the safari so
this web driver is not only static for
one browser
it's actually approachable for across
multiple browsers there so that enhances
the compatibility there that yes this
set test suit
even if you're writing the test suits in
case of selenium it's not limited to one
browser so it's kind of a cross browser
here
so these are small small benefits
although we are talking about the
selenium webdriver here
but if you closely see these all points
are actually defining
why exactly the selenium is best uh when
we talk about the weber
automations or the web testing
automation here right
and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages
like uh programming languages yes it's
there it's even
supporting different browsers and then
of course it's
supporting different operating systems
also because
you can pretty much run these test cases
uh onto linux macs or
windows whatever the platform you feel
like you want to use
you can pretty much use it so you don't
have to worry about like where exactly
this web driver
is getting deployed and from where you
are trying to refer it
so that kind of compatibility is also
something
which is available here so you don't
have to think about the
specific different uh versions or the
different
operating systems as such over here and
then let's talk about
further on this one so it also provides
the compatibility across different
programming languages so you can see
like what are the different benefits you
got
you got benefits like uh you know it's
it's supporting different programming
languages
it's supporting different browsers and
ultimately at last it's supporting the
different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here
so these are small small things like
different uh benefits which we get with
the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so
uh it doesn't matter that if you're
working with java or if you're working
with dot net
this is going to work for across a
different different platforms like
different uh
environments you can actually deploy so
these benefits are something which can
definitely help you to see like how the
overall
uh benefits can be achieved over here
and
uh definitely the chrome browsers are
the safari
the firefox the oprah different uh
platforms you will be able to see like
how the execution needs to be done and
how the setup
used to be performed here so that's
where the complete uh
implementations uh needs to be performed
here right
and uh these web driver provides a
faster execution of the desk scripts
uh because that's uh the kind of
automation which we are looking forward
that we are not trying to see like how
the systems can be implemented so when
we are trying to talk about the
automation here
so these web drivers basically help us
to go for the faster execution also
so it's not only about uh that we are
trying to uh see the
setup like we are trying to go for the
configurations here
it's also like uh the performance and
the efficiency which we're getting with
this one is quite beneficial
so you can get an easy and a faster
execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about
in these features only itself you can
see like there are a lot of benefits
which we got
over here so it's fast it's efficient
and on top of that
it's not depending on any kind of
environment
it's quite generic like you know it's
something which you can use for
windows you can use it for linux you
want to use it for
dotnet you want to use it for java it's
kind of uh
chandrick for a lot of technologies
platforms and programming languages
right now why exactly we require the
selenium web driver
like what is the purpose of using this
one so let's explore on that part here
so selenium fib driver provides a
user-friendly interface
that could uh you know it can be easily
understood by a particular person like
when we uh
when you're using this selenium web
driver so this is something which
you can easily understood like it's
pretty easy for you to understand that
and
it's not that much complex for you to
understand that okay you are going to
take a lot of time to
consume you're going to take a lot of
time to uh you know understand that so
that's not a kind of
interface which we are getting when we
talk of the
selenium web driver here right and uh
the web driver uh is something which is
having uh much more uh features as
compared to the
uh selenium rc and selenium ide there so
when we talk about the
uh selenium web driver so this is
something which is having
uh much more features as compared to the
other components like you know these the
other components is also about the
selenium only but yes
the when we talk about selenium uh web
drivers so it's
having much more features as compared to
the selenium rc and the selenium ide
here
so you don't have to worry about the
features like all together selenium uh
driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so
that's another benefit which we get with
the selenium here
so selenium uh we have got some other
components like a selenium
remote control here so uh rc is
something which enables the
uh the creation of uh you know automated
web applications like uh in in case of
programming languages such as java c
sharp uh node.js different different
programming languages are there so we
can pretty much
use the remote control selenium remote
control over here
which will enable the uh the creation of
the automated
web applications there so that's the
purpose of using the
selenium remote control here it's uh
it's not something which is being used
nowadays
because most of the functionalities have
nowadays moved on to the
uh selenium driver here so
that's some migration which has happened
over there and that's the reason why we
are not going to use
much of the selenium remote control over
here so that's not being used as such
as compared to the other components but
yes the selenium
webdriver is something which is quite
popular and because of its features
and the efficiency we are going to use
of the particular uh
browse the uh web driver as compared to
the any other component
as such here right now selenium ide
um needs not additional any kind of
setup is required
like uh you know apart from installation
of the browser because uh in that case
everything will be integrated in that
like because we are using
we are integrating the complete uh
selenium ide over here
so all you need to do is like you need
to do the installation of chrome browser
that's also because you want to go for
the
uh specific chrome driver which you
require for the execution of the test
cases so for that only you are basically
trying to install the chrome browser but
other than that there is no other
component which you actually require
when we talk about the
selenium ide here
so the ide makes the life
easy because it helps us to go ahead
with the debugging mode here
like a kind of a debugging environment
you will be able to do that
so even if there is any kind of issue
any any kind of problem which comes up
so it will be very easy for you to debug
those things and go ahead with that part
so uh tracking the exceptions managing
the exception so all those things can be
easily handled
with the help of the selenium ide here
so selenium ide is something which is
kind of a bigger package which is
uh further comprising of different
different components like it's something
which
is giving us a variety of things here
right
now how exactly the uh selenium whip
driver is
at all different from the selenium rc
and ide because those are also the
solution which is available there from
this lane now unlike the selenium ide
selenium web driver can actually work
with different browsers so that's
something which we have already focused
on that it's having the compatibility
across
multiple uh browsers there that's the
first benefit which we get over
here in this one now also the web
drivers is something which does not
require
any user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of
a selenium rc you have to start some
server because
you're ultimately connecting to that
server and that's how the communication
is happening
but that kind of stuff is not there in
the uh selenium uh web driver here
also this linear web driver is an api
and it's not a gui based plugin so
uh it's it's something which can easily
handle like
it's having the um quite efficient uh
connectivity or you can say like the uh
integration is also good there because
we
most of the applications nowadays are
working on the api format which is
pretty generic
so we there is no gui based interface
which we have to explore which we need
to integrate here so it's all like
the api's call which we need to do in
order to use uh make use of the
selenium web driver here now in selenium
webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium rc and
selenium id so which is not a kind of
object oriented in nature but selenium
webdriver is something which is
quite object oriented here also uh
web driver the selenium webdriver is
actually uh supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium rc and
selenium id here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there
also it also supports the testing of the
ios and android which is not being
supported in the
rc and ide there because most of the
applications
nowadays also have the counterpart uh
android or the ios applications
so if you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms
then it's a incomplete way of testing
here so not only the web applications
but even the mobile applications also
now getting integrated with the help of
the
selenium web driver here so these kind
of features which is not exactly
available in the rc or the
id over here but definitely it's it's
going to be available there in case of
selenium web driver
so what exactly is the overall need of
the web driver like the selenium
webdriver here
so uh let's talk about that that uh how
exactly we can use it for the software
automation here so there are a couple of
benefits which is available there so
let's focus on that one by one
the very first one is the open source
now it's something which is available
or which is uh available as an open
source over here
which means like uh it's something which
you can use without any license without
any cost
uh just like that you can go to the
selenium.dev website and you can start
downloading the
uh selenium related uh details or
selenium related components
second is multilingual support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages
not only for the java based applications
it's actually supporting like different
different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool
and then can serve eyes or that can
support multiple programming languages
here
several operating system support yes
it's not only related to the
windows or linux platform here so it's
actually supported
across uh windows linux
macos different operating systems are
actually supported here so different
support operating systems is supported
by this
particular selenium here multiple
frameworks are there so that's a
multiple framework support which is
available in this one
uh user friendly it's quite user
friendly there and the developers were
more comfortable with the java
programming languages
so they get uh quite uh comfortable and
integrated with the
selenium because it's also using the
same java syntax over here in this one
um it's cross device testing uh
definitely both mobile desktops
are different platforms different
operating systems mac os
uh ios android different uh platforms
are actually supported
by this uh particular selenium here so
selenium web driver is something which
is having like
cross device testing here community
support is there
it's kind of open source yes but uh it's
having a very good community like a lot
of people are actually there
who can contribute to this selenium you
can get the information from there and
it's kind of a
huge efforts like a kind of a huge
community efforts which you can
see over here in this case also a
compatibility testing so it's having a
very good compatibility here so
uh when you're working with this uh
selenium so it's
compatible with pretty much any
programming languages
any platform any operating system so
that kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here
and uh unlike uh selenium rc
you don't have to start any kind of
server component here uh which you need
to connect so it's like uh
on demand like when you're running the
scripts a kind of a local chrome browser
will be uh initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
uh performed and
that that's how the whole executions
will be performed there so there is no
involved like you have to go somewhere
start some server
start somewhere remote server there and
then the communication or the execution
of the test cases will be initialized so
it's not like that kind of communication
here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver
architecture here now in this one there
are some different
components which is available there in
this architecture components
the very first one is the selenium
language bindings here
now these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like java ruby
python c-sharp javascript these are the
different programming languages bindings
which is available there
then with the help of json wire protocol
these are going to be connected to the
different drivers
now browser drivers is the one where
exactly the request will be sent out
so this selenium web driver is actually
going to connect or send the request to
these drivers
so um depending on the platform also and
depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for chrome driver you want to go for
firefox you want to go for opera you
want to go for safari
these are the different browsers which
is available there earlier the
internet explorer was also there but now
in the latest version say it
each browser or h driver is something
which is available there
and uh these are going to be connected
to the actual uh
particular browsers like the chrome
firefox and also
it will be sending the request over the
http
uh http uh that request will be sent out
to the real drivers so the browser
drivers and then the real drivers will
be there
so the web driver is going to connect to
the chrome driver
and then in fact from there the chrome
driver is going to
initialize the chrome browser and then
the whole request will be processed the
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case
so these are the different steps which
is involved
when we are basically going for uh from
one step to another like where the
communications
or will be performed over here in this
case right
so uh again it's not dependent on any
programming
languages it's not dependent on any kind
of browser or any kind of components
here
so right from the uh language bindings
it will go to the json wire protocol
from there it will be sent out to the
browser drivers various browser drivers
whatever the browser drivers you want to
use
you can use that and then those drivers
are actually going to connect with the
real drivers or with the
real browsers over here so that the
communications or the
exact end result you should be able to
see so
for instance if you run a particular
chrome browser uh chrome driver there
so you will be able to see like a chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that
activity will be happened or will be
performed over there so these are the
parts of the
sequence these are kind of architecture
components like one to another these
will be
processed or these will be executed here
right
so uh these programming language these
selenium programming languages again
it's
actually a kind of a generic one so
these are the
client libraries which is available
there depending on this one for example
for java i can download some binaries uh
i can download some jar files so that
will be
referenced or utilized into my source
code for ruby it's maybe like different
uh
third party libraries or shared
libraries which will be available there
for python it will be available in the
form of modules uh c sharp javascript
so each and every programming languages
is actually having its
own libraries now these libraries are
actually required
so that we can get the whole interface
of the selenium it's okay like i'm
writing some test cases
i'm writing the complete test sort and
i'm using it but unless and until i
import my selenium libraries it will not
work for me
i will not be able to work on that part
because i will not be able to get those
features as such
in order to get those features i need to
download these bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language
and these are easily available on the
selenium website so if you go to the
selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings
these windings will be nothing but the
archives where you will be having some
kind of
executables depending on that
programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these
bindings in order to interact in order
to initialize the selenium
so then we will be going to the json
wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers
now uh programmatically are using these
with the help of these uh
client libraries we're going to send the
request to the web drivers
it also helps to enable the transfer of
data between a server and client
because of course uh you have to get
your end result process
right so that's where you need to go for
the execution so what you're going to do
is like you're going to see like okay
i'm going to run or i'm going to execute
this
uh json wire protocol over here and it's
going to connect between my client
libraries
and the web drivers here so that's the
communications and the connectivity
which we want to establish or we want to
provide here
now these uh selenium browser drivers
are actually uh
specific browsers now because um the
json wire is going to connect uh to the
uh specific
browsers uh the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen
now uh these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the
exact browser now if you want to
interact with the chrome
then you definitely have to use the
chrome driver if you want to use for the
fireworks then you have to use the
firefox driver
so depending on the programming language
you have to define
like which driver you really need to
process or you need to really
go ahead with that part so that's where
the selenium browser drivers
really comes into the picture and then
uh
the exact browsers will be there now
once the
executions will be done at last you will
be able to see like all these browsers
getting open
if you're going to use the chrome
browser then chrome browser will be
initialized
if you're using the firefox then the
firefox browser will be initialized
so whatever the browser or driver
specific driver you will utilize
so according to that you will see a
particular browser
being invoked over here so that's how
the communication happens and it's kind
of a sequence here like step by step
here
so each and every stage is very
important because that's how the
uh communication will happen over here
and you will get the end result or the
desired output
if you uh have any kind of uh failing
component over here
so that's where the whole connectivity
will be breakdown and you will not be
able to get
any kind of values x expected so
this is something which we really need
to consider or we need to go ahead with
that part here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more so what are the different
drawbacks which we got with the help of
the selenium webdriver here so when we
talk about the
selenium webdriver so what are the
different drawbacks which we are getting
over here
so that we can understand like how
exactly we can
talk about that part here now the
drawbacks of
selenium webdriver is something which we
uh you know use because
this is kind of a main component you can
say like you know using which
you can actually do the complete
validation but the problem is that
it's not something which you can use for
the desktop application so for the
desktop application this does not works
so this web driver is something which is
supported for the web applications only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such
so that's a kind of a limitation which
we get with the help of the
selenium web driver here so it's only
there for the websites for the web
portals
secondly uh the uh it requires the
expertise of the teams
uh you know in order to manage these
scripts because these are the
programming languages of course there
although it's a test suit but uh it
requires a programming language efforts
as such in order to go ahead with that
in order to manage these things
so it requires a kind of expert team
who can actually handle these scripts or
who can work on these requirements
so uh that's a kind of overheat because
if it's not like very easy to manage
these like uh pretty much a person who
is an expert in these things can only
handle these kind of requirements so
it's kind of a limitation where we will
be only depending on an expert
to manage these scripts as such right
now um it's not having any kind of uh
reporting inbuilt reporting capability
over here so
it's not available in this one so test
reports which is
getting generated here is uh with the
help of the junit and test ng
so there is no default reporting
mechanism which is available over here
in this one so we
only have the mechanism of the junit
like we can extend
our test scripts in selenium by
integrating with jh unit and the test ng
here
so that we will be able to get a proper
reporting
so for the uh reporting purposes we
actually use the components like this
junit and the test ng over here to go
ahead with that
so these are the ways in which we can
actually go for the integration where we
can integrate the selenium
and the other frameworks like junit and
the uh test ng kind of components here
and that's the whole basis because uh
alone the selenium webdriver is
something which can execute the scripts
process the
request but it's not going to handle any
kind of
reporting mechanism so reporting
mechanism is something which you can
only get with the help of the junit or
the test
ng here because these are the additional
packages which you need to integrate
so it's it's a kind of a custom solution
which we need to design
uh you know where we don't have only the
web driver
available over here like the core
components but also we have like other
components available over there which
will be of course having the other
components like test ng and the j unit
here so that's also something which you
can integrate
all together with this one right also uh
it's very difficult to manage there is a
lot of management
or the maintenance activity which we get
over here
also it's very difficult to scale this
up also depending on the load or
depending on the requirement
it's very difficult to scale it up also
if you are using for some infrastructure
some
kind of a load there so having it
increased to a different level is kind
of a difficult task here
also maintenance activity is quite huge
so if you want to have
a proper maintenance or management you
have to get
a couple of uh you know experts in that
case so that they can easily manage
those things so
these are the different uh requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the
uh we can you know manage all these
things now
it also uh you know allows the across
browser uh compatibility testing here so
uh it's something which can easily
handle like different
requests across the browsers so um image
testing is not available
so uh you don't have to uh you know use
the selenium alone like selenium alone
is not
compatible for testing the images here
so if you really want to test the images
so you have to
integrate securely uh in with your
selenium so that you can have a complete
package
so again uh selenium in some cases is
not sufficient for
like most or a variety of things there
so in some cases you have to actually
go for another tool integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the uh real mechanism
comes in like
yes you don't have the exact single tool
available for taking care of
all these things but yes you can have
all these things integrated
with the other tools other components
there and from there you will be able to
get a complete
values and the complete implementation
here
right so these are the uh you know
different uh
drawbacks which we get once we start
using the
a web driver here so let's go ahead uh
with the
uh particular demo over here to
understand like how
exactly the selenium web driver can be
utilized can be used
so that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so we are going to run
a prepare a test suit here so that we
can get it executed with the help of
selenium
so that's what we are trying to do here
so for this one we require some couple
of components to be there
like the jdk eclipse and all so let's
talk about that component so let's go
ahead with the
implementation so let's begin with the
uh
configurations of the swift webdriver
here now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the java here now let's
uh go ahead with this
url so now this one is something where
we have to see like how
we can go for the installation of the
jdk here
now here we need to go for the jdk
installation that's the version which we
want to install
now it a variety of versions are
available there like which version you
want to
install you can go with that uh jdk 11
8 it is the most stable version so you
can go ahead with the jdk 8 here
so you can download here different
platforms it's available like windows
platform
uh whatever the platform is there all
you need to do is like you need to just
download this exe file
now once the exe file is downloaded so
what happens like you will be able to do
the installation
now i have done the installation of this
jdk here so
if i have to open my uh command prompt
here
i would be easily able to see that i'm
using a jdk version
of 1.8.0 over here in this one
so that's a version which i'm using but
again of course
if you're using some different version
of cdk that will also work here
the only thing is that you need to see
that you need to go for a compatible
browser
a compatible uh java and the compatible
eclipse tool here so that's what you
require
now what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to install or download the eclipse
browser also now let's
download the eclipse here now we got an
official website of eclipse here
from where we can download these eclipse
different platform you can do it like
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here
so uh here the uh download will work
just like that you can do the download
here even if you want to go for a
different
offerings like you want to go for
different platform
you feel like you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um ide eclipse ide for the java
developers
for uh the c plus c plus plus so
different uh different uh
operating system and different uh
packages are also available there
so it's basically up to you like which
exactly environment you want to follow
so i want to download this uh 64 bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here
now uh let's again download this this is
kind of an exe file which is available
here
so let's download it again now um
it will be working on like uh it's kind
of a download
which is getting started over here so
it's close to 102 mb which is available
there this is the executable
which is going to help us to do the
installation of eclipse
now this is the uh latest version our
2020 version is what it is getting
installed over here
and uh it's completely there i have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that
using this jdk the eclipse will be open
if you don't have the jdk installed the
java runtime then the eclipse will not
be installed for you so
uh in order to get the eclipse uh
installed and executable perfectly fine
you need uh the jdk installed to be done
here
so we got like one more minute here to
complete the download and this is just
102 mb
package or installer which is available
there and once this is installed we will
be able to get ahead with this
installation of the eclipse here
so once the eclipse is installed all you
can do is like you can go ahead with the
uh particular configurations you can
create some couple of
cro uh projects in case of eclipse
um then we'll also see like how we can
download the
programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download
so these are the different components
which you are going to explore while
working on this one so
uh let's wait for this uh download of
this executable to be performed here
so that we will be able to proceed
further with this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and eclipse both are the
open source one
you're getting a donate to a class
community page there because that's the
donation which they want
but again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here
so you don't have to pay any cost as
such over here in this case so there is
no cost associated with this one
so just 10 seconds more and then we can
pursue with the installation of the
eclipse here
and here we go so the installer is
almost done here so i can pretty much
go ahead and open the file so this will
help me to do the installation of the
eclipse here
so the eclipse installer is what it's
getting started initialized over here in
this one
uh now the java runtime is already
available with me
we require the uh specific uh
jdk installed the java command line is
working we can download the eclipse here
and then we can go for the uh
specific executions like we can go and
uh download the
uh browser drivers here now the thing is
that
if you really want to go for the chrome
browser or firefox or any kind of those
things
in case of your particular system in
case of your windows machine over here
you don't have to necessarily go for any
kind of uh
a kind of a driver as such here because
of the fact
we got a links over here like uh this
mozilla for the firefox
uh this one is there for the uh
particular selenium
this one is there for the chrome now
chrome is something which we have
already got here like we have already
got the
chrome browser installed but
let's see like uh we can download this
driver also like uh depending on that we
can go ahead with that part
and then we can also download the java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the specific
selenium.dev website over there and
we can download and we can integrate it
so let's do it one by one so first of
all let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done
and then we'll be able to go ahead with
the third component or the third
request which is the a web driver or a
particular chrome browser a driver over
here
so this installer is going to give us
the same thing here so i'm going for the
uh specific java developer here so let's
go for the uh installation here
now this is going to uh install uh the
uh
java 8 right uh this runtime over here
so
if you feel like you want to use the jdk
11 because that's something which is
available there
now if you using an existing ones like
uh
you're already using uh an existing once
over here the jdk and all so
uh that's where the installation is
going on like it's it's going in with
that part here
but we already got some system related
uh jdks which is installed but uh you
feel like you want to go ahead with this
one
um like you're not doing this separate
installation of the jdk
or jre so there you can actually use
this once here
so let's select this one like i pretty
much want to use like
any one of these uh jvms over here like
which i feel like i can configure or i
can utilize so that's pretty much we can
do here
so it's like uh we can use these
variables like we can go for these jvms
or if you feel like you can go for an
external jvm also there so it all
depends on you like how the
uh installation you want to perform here
right and this is the location let's uh
go for the
desktop location there and or you can go
for the default location also over here
in this one
so let's go for the installation now
just accept it
and uh the installation will be
proceeded over here so
uh even if you have not done a separate
jtag installation so this will basically
have
a jdk installed i have selected the java
11 over here
uh but you can go for the 15 also in
this case in this scenario so the whole
installation of the eclipse is what it's
happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like
uh dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components
and chrome browser again it's already
something which is installed there but
we'll see like how we can download the
chrome driver
how we can configure and we can utilize
that so that's what we're going to
follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something uh which we are trying
to do
like uh it's this installer is pretty
much downloading some couple of
components as such uh like this j uh
jre is something which is getting
installed or downloaded from the
eclipse website and uh that's where the
uh you know all the components is
getting installed so one by one all the
components will be downloaded
from the eclipse website here and it's a
complete package which means like you
don't have to necessarily go
for a separate installation there is
another installer which is available for
eclipse where you just have to unzip
up for a zip file and you can pretty
much use it but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside
that so that's an another component
which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there so
uh it depends because all these things
are getting cached
up from the internet so it also depends
on like how much
size of file is getting downloaded here
so let's
uh you know let's wait for the
installations to be complete
and then we'll proceed further so now
the installation is done so we can
launch our eclipse here so that's what
we are trying to launch here
now apart from eclipse what happens like
we require some other components also
like uh we require this lithium web
driver also there
so for that we have to download the uh
java related client bindings
so for that uh chrome browser first of
all it's already installed so we don't
have to do any kind of installation
there
uh yes i can go ahead with the exe file
like of the chrome browser driver
that i'm going to use it so i'm going to
open the uh specific downloads here now
in this segment what happens like
selenium.dev is the website which is
available there now here we can go for
the downloads
now related to your programming language
whatever the programming language you
are trying to use so you can download
the language binding for that
now language binding is something which
is utilized so using which you will be
able to see like how
uh you can establish the connectivity
it's just a kind of a libraries where
you can do the connectivity and you can
see that execution
so what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to download this bindings here
so let's download this one now it's
again available as in zip file which is
available there so uh
depending on the version you can go for
the beta download version also
and i'm going for the stable version
which we want to utilize we want to
refer it
so it's going to download zip file so
this zip file will have all the jar
files and all the
required libraries there and when i'm
going to create a project into my
eclipse
at that moment of time i would be
requiring all these components like all
these
uh various uh libraries i should be
added up into my
uh project as such in case of the
eclipse so that's what i need to do here
so let's go to the eclipse here so here
we're going to expand this
like a package explorer and here we're
going to
go to file new and java project
so i'm going to create a java project
over here so um
in which we will be getting some couple
of class files in which we will be
having the
selenium-related test cases like how we
want to process or how we want to
execute that part
so i'm going to proceed with that part
so let's put the uh
project name here so i'm going to say
like selenium
just a project name i want to put uh
then the jdk
now uh if you want to go for a specific
jdk like another version so you can go
with that but right now i'm using like
jdk 1.8 which is pretty much configured
so i can use that
uh you feel like you want to use the
specific jre of
uh gre which is available as part of jdk
1.8 that also you can use or if you want
to use like a jdk so that also something
which you can utilize over here in this
one so there are different things like
you can configure the gres also
so if you have some custom path which uh
where you have the java available
or the jdk or jre is available there so
that also you can easily refer it so you
can simply say that yes uh this so and
so location
i want to refer i want to see my source
code so that's where you can do the
you can go for the execution now once
you're providing these values like
the install gres which you want to
provide which you want to process here
next thing what you need to perform is
like you need to go ahead with that
execution
so i'm completely okay with the jdk
whatever the environment i want to
process
i can easily do that and i'm completely
okay with that
right so uh let's go with that part and
then click on
next and uh this is the source directory
which is available there right and uh if
you want to add any additional libraries
so uh here exactly you can add your
selenium related libraries
using which you will be able to see your
source code working fine but i'm not
going to do that activity here
so i'm going to do that later on so that
we can get a complete things in a
sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gi related libraries and the source
folder here
so right now it's completely empty
project there is nothing available as
such here
and what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to create a class file over here
to see with the specific source code of
the selenium to how the web driver is
getting loaded up and processed so
that's stuff we are going to talk about
here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this
selenium programming language bindings
here so let me extract it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also
or if you wish you can keep it aside in
some specific folder because
it's just going to be referenced with
every project so it's just
kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of a
package or this kind of share library
you can easily utilize and you can
implement it
so we are just trying to extract it now
once extraction is done so you will be
able to see like some couple of files
and folders
uh now this is having a particular uh
two executable files like client embed
combined
this is kind of connecting uh acting
like a selenium client and which is
using to connect and
uh process all the requirements and we
also have a sources file which is
available there for this one
but again uh it's something which
depends on the requirement so
you don't have to put these sources uh
jar file also over here because that's
not required
so you can pretty much uh use this
executable jar file because in this one
you will not have any kind of source
then of course your selenium related jar
file is
further on depending on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are
also uh something which you should be
putting up into your
uh specific uh shared library so that
your selenium related jar file should
not started failing so
uh we'll we'll try that scenario also so
that we can get the complete
output and complete in chance here so
let's see
now uh we'll go to this uh we'll import
this particular file over there
and for that we have to write a class
file so let's see like how we can do
that so we have already got the selenium
web driver so
uh the eclipse is what we have followed
so we have created a new
java project now we want to create a new
class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that later on but right
now we are going to see like how we can
proceed further with that so i i'm going
for this uh specific component here
right so uh whatever the browser or
whatever the
driver you want to follow you can do
that so firefox if you want to use you
want to use our chrome
browser it all depends on you like it
all depends on the
way that how you want to configure it so
uh let's see
let's uh import this uh particular
component here now if the
uh specific uh firefox browser is
installed that's great if it's not
installed so you can just go
back here so here you will be able to
see like this browsers
like these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want uh
like if you want to use for the chrome
browser you can go for
that if you want to go for the firefox
edge whatever the driver you feel like
you want to go you can do
go with that part here so let's uh open
this one here
and extract this one also so that we
should be able to refer it over here
into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there
now all we need to do is like we need to
just open our eclipse there so
uh in our eclipse we should be using or
we should be referring to this one here
so this is a kind of a path which is
available
similarly we will also be giving a path
over there so that uh we can
refer to that specific uh driver that
driver over here so let me open that and
uh
let's see so i'm going to create a class
file here
you can create a package uh called
com and uh in that package you can
further on create a class file
like
selenium test uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name
so uh you feel like you want to give
some different name
you can uh go for
uh you know any kind of class name over
here but this is something which is
uh something we are going to see like
how the execution should needs to be
performed and needs to be
done here so there are different uh you
know
names like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here
now in this one you're getting some
errors uh related to this one like
you're getting the uh
error codes related to the imports here
like how the
uh specific execution should be done
here right
now the thing is that uh this is
something which is uh really causing the
problems uh like how the import or
the execution should be done right also
uh
the thing is that uh we require these
imports to be available there
right so uh that's definitely we are
requiring over here
and uh that's that's something which we
uh require
uh we want to process as such also so
right now let's uh have an uh particular
declaration of the
uh package also there because it's
something which is there in the comp
package so let's have the
package com also here so it's there in
the com package
but again those errors are not related
to that so these are like related to the
configurations which we are trying to
put
and uh during the copy paste there might
be a conversion of the code so
that i have taken care great so uh let's
see
now what i have to really do is like we
have to see like how we can proceed
further
on the uh for the most executions and we
need to get this driver like we need to
get this one
so i'll right click on my project here
and go to the build path
and click on configure build path so
first i'm going to
uh add my binding jar file there the
java binding the jar file which i
downloaded
just now this client combined one here
so only this jar file we are trying to
add up over here
and with that most of the uh related
errors
related to that uh imports will be
resolved now i'm not sure that how
it's going to work how it's going to uh
you know function whether it's going to
success or failure that's a different
story
but yes all you have done is like i
right clicked on my project
went to the build path went to the
configure build path here
and went for the add external charge so
these are the external jars which you
have to do
we have to put up over here so only the
combined client combined jar file is
what i have put up over here in this one
in the reference libraries you will
immediately be able to know that part of
the jar file here
now this is the directory where you will
be having the exe file available
for that driver for the firefox so let's
get the path for our component also so
we got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the
folder where we got our driver available
here and let's try to resolve it let's
try to run it over here
great so now i'm going to right click
here
just say run as and java application
now in this one i got an error saying
that some com
google common collect imitable map some
class file is not available there this
is of the fact that i did not
imported those uh dependent jar files
also which we
got downloaded from the uh java binding
file here
so that zip file was also having some of
the jar files there in the library
folders
so in this one also you will be able to
see like some executions of the jar
files is required over here
as an inputs as a standard imports so
let's import this one and
this is the reason why we got the error
at the first place because we are not
importing those ones
those jar files which is being required
by our client
combined jar file also so these are the
dependent jar files which we are trying
to import here
so ultimately at last you will be able
to have your referenced
libraries available here with all these
jar files component available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now i have the chrome browser but
unfortunately i don't have the firefox
browser so let's go ahead
and download the firefox browser so for
that
let's open the browser so i'm going to
download a
firefox browser over here into my system
so the official website is something
which is quite good so we can go for the
download firefox here
now uh why because i require now i'm
using the firefox here if i am
using the chrome browser i will not be
having or facing any kind of issues as
such but since
i'm using the firefox driver so i
require firefox browser so
uh the uh dependency of the uh browser
is there when we want to go ahead
because
uh pretty much my uh core base is going
to connect or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver
ultimately internally or require a
browser
show that it can now perform these
occasions it can do that execution
so these drivers are going to just uh
communicate
between the your source code and the uh
actual browser here
so uh after the driver you also require
the browser to be installed
like the chrome browser to be available
here so that you can pretty much use it
and you can perform the configuration
so let's see uh we are getting the
browser over here in this one
and uh we got the browser installed
perfectly fine over here
so we should be able to see the browser
uh because in this one we are basically
trying to open the browser and
getting a website called www.google.com
here
and then we are having a particularly
one and then ultimately the driver is
getting cured here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as
java application so you will be able to
see the browsing here so okay it's
connecting
the uh browser the firefox exe file is
getting executed
a browser is getting executed and it
will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here
and uh we just have to wait for a couple
of seconds more
and uh here we go we got the a browser
closed automatically also because there
was a slip of
a couple of seconds over here and you
got the failure like you got the
complete
uh component or it got the driver closed
there driver closed means that
definitely the browser will also be
closed here
and you can see here that the uh
specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here
it's actually showing us like how the
executions and the
uh setup needs to be performed or needs
to be done here
so this is the way that how
the bra the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case
you got the browser execution and
everything will be work perfectly fine
so again i'm right clicking over here
just click on run as java
application the same browser will be
open again
uh it will be automatically refreshed
you will see that progress
like this and after a couple of seconds
uh the thread will be on sleep but yes
after that it will be closed
automatically over
here so like that you can program
how to open your website how to proceed
further from there
you want to click on some buttons you
want to do some processing
that's all up to you like how you
program how you code it over here
so this completely helps you to see like
how exactly you can go ahead with the
complete program
and this program will help you to
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases
so this is what we have in this demo
where we saw like how we can configure
the different drivers
the web driver the browser driver and
ultimately the browser
and the selenium web driver here so
you're using the selenium web driver
over here which is going to invoke the
browser driver and this browser driver
is going to invoke the browser as such
over here in this case
so that's it for this demo let's move on
to main content
so that was the demo in which we
executed a very simple program in order
to execute the
selenium web driver which is going to
further invoke the
uh browser driver the firefox driver and
then it was invoking the
specific implementations there right so
this is what we did
and if we summarize this demo so in this
one we downloaded uh the selenium web
driver we installed it we configured it
we integrated the eclipse with the uh
selenium web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be booked
and the previous cases yes the browser
was invoking a www.google.com website
there
and we were getting the response
accordingly and that was the executions
mechanism like that's the whole basis
that how the selenium test cases used to
work and
used to be integrated over there so this
is the complete way that how
exactly we did this demo here so pretty
much that's the module which we were
trying to explain today to
understand to make you understand that
what is the benefits of using the
selenium
how we are getting the different
benefits out of selenium and the biggest
benefit is
like how in a non-interactive mode you
can see the progress you can see the
validation happening there so all you
need to do is like you need to just
click on one button
and the whole processing will be done
and these kind of automations is quite
beneficial when you talk about the
scientific testing the smoke testing
any kind of validations are going on
there so that's where the
selenium integrations really works here
so that's it for this module thanks
everyone
bye-bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here